dollars to support efforts to increase
vaccine distribution and access
with a specific focus on communities of
color
also today in his weekly update i said
part of the same call i should
say for clarity uh covert response
coordinator jeff zions announced there
will be more than 28 million doses
across channels this week
cumulatively over the past three weeks
we will have sent out nearly 90 million
doses of the vaccine
he also stressed to governors that while
we continue to make strong
progress it is critical that we continue
to mask up and social existence
josh why don't you kick us out thanks
jen uh on the
vaccine and vaccination announcement
uh we've kind of known for weeks that
you'd see this ramp up in production and
i'm curious
like why move up the timeline now
is there a desire to make sure that
people who are hesitant
or reluctant to get a vaccine feel like
they can do so
what's the thinking there well first the
president had
already announced that he was asking
states to move up their timelines
so this is more providing clarity to the
american public
who may tune in to the president's
remarks or clips that you all share on
the news that
they're all eligible it creates provides
clarity uh it reduces confusion
and it ensures that americans who are
not yet vaccinated who are looking to
get vaccinated
they know they are all eligible all
adults i should say on april 19th
and then secondly it's been about a week
since the president announced his
infrastructure plan
lots of states county cities are
wondering how they would qualify for any
money
do you have any details on what that
process would look like
sure um well first uh ultimately
it will be up to congress and something
we'll have a conversation with members
and committees about that's part of the
why it's so important to engage at a
committee level and staff level and many
of you who have been through
a journey like this before know this but
let me just reiterate some of the pieces
of the process
uh funding for transportation process
for transportation projects can
typically be allocated
through two different types of grants
and we expect a mix
to be discussed either formula grants or
competitive grants
so formula grants are allocated to
states based on certain criteria
like the number of miles on an
interstate highway or a population in a
given
urban area most of our existing
transportation
funding flows through formula grants
which gives states a lot of flexibility
on how to prioritize and spend their
federal dollars based on what their
needs are
competitive grants are a more targeted
way to direct funds to specific policy
goals
often based on criteria set by congress
for example
the popular tiger grant program that was
set up in the recovery act
considered how a project can uh could
contribute to job creation and that was
one of the big factors that was
determined
as uh programs were being or states were
applying for funding
we've also mentioned the
administration's proposal for a
competitive grant program to fund
10 of the most economically significant
bridges in the country so that type of
application
would be through competitive grants so
again this is something that we will be
working through with congress with
committees of jurisdiction
though it will be a mix of those two
type of grants would be our expectation
and estates who all have excellent
questions including local reporters we
engage with
that that is what they can expect in
terms of the process
uh go ahead thank you the fbi keeps a
watch list of information about people
who are known
or reasonably suspected of being
involved in terror activities
two people on it from yemen have been
apprehended at the border how concerned
is president about terrorists possibly
trying to take advantage of
gas in the border to get in and kill
americans
well first let me convey that uh these
type of incidents are very uncommon
uh and cbp and dhs can speak more to
uh the timeline and the specifics of
course in these particular
cases and encounters but encounters of
known and suspected terrorists are very
uncommon
uh they do underscore the importance of
the critical work that is done
on a daily basis to vet those at the
border dhs works
not just in at the border as you know
but also with international partners to
share intelligence and other information
including to prevent individuals
on certain watch lists from entering the
united states
they adjudicate individuals encountered
at and between ports of entry against
several classified
and unclassified databases so while this
is rare this is a reflection of them
doing their jobs another question about
the border the dhs secretary is
reportedly looking to
finish some gas in the southern border
how does that fit with president biden's
day one executive order to stop
border wall construction well wall
construction remains
paused to the extent permitted by law so
some has already been
funded through uh congressional uh
authorization
and funding allocation uh but as
agencies uh
develop for a plan it's paused while
agencies are developing
developing a plan for the president on
the management of the federal funds
when the administration took office as
you referenced funds had been diverted
from congressionally appropriated
military construction projects
uh and other appropriated purposes
toward building the wall
and while construction was being
challenged in multiple lawsuits
and for much of the wall i should say
not all of it by plaintiffs who allege
serious environmental and safety issues
under those circumstances federal
agencies are continuing to review walk
on
tracks and develop a plan to submit to
the president soon it is it is paused
there is some limited construction that
has been funded and allocated for but it
is
otherwise paused and then uh is the
white house concerned that major league
baseball is moving their all-star game
to colorado where
voting regulations are very similar to
georgia
well let me just revere refute
the first point you made first let me
say
um on colorado um
colorado uh allows you to register on
election day
uh colorado has voting by mail where
they send to 100
of people in the state uh who are
eligible uh applications to vote by mail
94
of people in colorado voted by mail in
the 2020
election uh and they also allow for
a range of um materials to provide
even if they vote on election day for
the limited number of people who
who vote on election day i think it's
important to remember the context here
the georgia legislation is built on a
lie
uh it's there was no widespread fraud in
the 2020 election
uh georgia's top republican election
officials have acknowledged that
repeatedly in interviews
uh and what there was however was
record-setting turnout
especially by voters of color so instead
what we're seeing here isn't
for politicians who didn't like the
outcome uh they're not changing their
policies uh to win more votes they're
changing the rules to exclude
more voters and we certainly see the
circumstances as different
but ultimately sorry let me add one more
thing it's up to major league baseball
to determine where they're
holding their all-star game okay a quick
one from a colleague who could not be
here
uh you're talking about the new vaccine
eligibility
deadline is the supply
ramping up quicker than expected
and if not what does moving the
eligibility deadline
up actually do in practice like are more
people going to get vaccinated faster
that's our hope absolutely and we have
expedited the supply so there's been
nearly 90 million
uh doses provided to states in just the
last three weeks and that certainly is
an increase
over the weeks prior that's part of it
but also we want to provide
clarity we're at the point with our
supply and with our distribution
uh two states that we think um you know
it's time to provide that level of
clarity now it's not just about the
vaccine supply we've also increased
uh the number of pharmacies more than
doubled the number of pharmacies that
are
distributing the vaccine we've also
increased our
commitment and our funding of community
health centers of mass vaccination sites
because we also know people need to
have places to go mobile vaccination
vehicles etc
all right i'll go ahead go ahead kelly
on the vaccine is this about
leading uh governors to move more
quickly or is this about reacting to
what governors have already done because
most states
have already moved their eligibility and
it sort of seems like the president is
now affirming a date that for many
people was already
the real and he had called for them to
move this date forward a couple of weeks
ago
so uh he had also called for the date to
move forward uh from may first as well
so he is certainly confirming for the
public
that everyone is eligible around the
country that is a great deal of clarity
they don't have to go to their local
state website and see when they're
eligible
they know that they are eligible on
april 19th every american out there who
is not vaccinated
this is also part of the effort here and
part of what he'll be conveying later
today
is to communicate to seniors and people
who have seniors in their community
maybe members of their family this is
the time to go now
to ensure seniors who are your loved
ones your family members
people in your neighborhood to go now
because the lines are going to become
longer
there are going to be more people
waiting uh so he'll also be sending that
clear message
so this is more about public education
and accomplishing a particular
goal is that services well we certainly
wouldn't be at this point
had we not uh purchased enough supply to
vaccinate every adult american
had we not increased our uh the number
of vaccinators who can distribute the
vaccine put them in shots and arms and
had we not massively increased our
investment in
places where people could go so it's a
signal that
one we're delivering clarity but also we
are at a point
where there are enough there's enough
supply there are enough vaccinators
there are enough vaccination sites that
every american
adult is eligible april 19th that is a
accomplishment for the medical field
it's an accomplishment for the people
who are running the operational
piece it's an accomplishment for the um
you know
the the medical experts locally who are
running these programs in different
states
briefly on georgia when uh the president
voiced his support for moving it does he
have any regret now that by doing that
by adding his voice
it may have contributed to the
environment where mlb
makes this decision and then there are
these economic consequences
to people in georgia when he and the
vice president were there and couldn't
do the car
rally and i've talked i wanted to thank
georgia george has been important to the
president vice president
electorally um is there a sense of
regret that perhaps he tipped the scale
uh with his rhetoric even if he doesn't
have a direct
cause and effect well he was answering a
direct question during an interview with
espn about the
opening day baseball something everybody
not everybody most people in the country
appreciate and enjoy and he was simply
conveying that
he would support that decision if that
decision was made by major league
baseball
just like he would support decisions
made by private sector companies
we're not standing here and calling for
companies to boycott
that's not what our focus is on from the
white house we do believe
that the focus on georgia and
is a reminder that and should be a
reminder i should say
that um this is much bigger than georgia
that
georgia was just one of the first states
to act on a concerted effort to use
easily disprovable conspiracy theories
to fuel their attempts to make it even
harder
for eligible americans to vote but
according to the brennan center
uh as of march 24th 361 bills
with restrictive provisions have been
introduced in 47 states
around the country so this is not just
georgia this
is something we are seeing a prevalence
of this a pattern
around the country of uh you know an
effort to make it more difficult to vote
mitch mcconnell the republican leader
still in kentucky
said uh many positive things about the
friendship and personal relationship
he's had with the president
up for a long time a fine man and so
forth also says a moderate he is not
does the president still identify as a
moderate within
the democratic party or do you feel that
he has moved
more or does the president feel he has
moved more to the progressive wing of
his own party
i don't think this will surprise you but
the president is not eager to be labeled
by
anyone in his party or certainly even by
his friend mitch mcconnell
and he is now president of the united
states he governs for all americans
uh he is encouraged by we all are
encouraged by the openness we've heard
from
uh some who would identify as moderate
democrats or republicans
of discussing components of the package
that he has proposed and he's looking
forward to having that conversation
go ahead john two questions on the
federal reserve board
is there any update on the um effort to
fill a vacancy the vacancy
on the federal reserve board of
governors i don't have any personnel
update for you i'm happy to check and
see if there's any update we can provide
thank you
and then also has president biden spoken
to the federal reserve chairman yet jay
powell
i don't have any call to read out either
you can't see if they've spoken yet at
all
i i don't have any update on it let us
know please if you i absolutely will
okay thank you very much and then also
um one other question about phone calls
has president
spoken to president obama about how to
pass the infrastructure bill has
president obama given him any advice
on how to pass that bill they speak
regularly uh they
of course were president and vice
president but they are also friends and
they share a bond of
serving through eight years of the obama
biden administration but
uh also a personal friendship and
kinship uh and he speaks with him
regularly but
uh we're not going to read out those
calls go ahead
jenny went through some of the numbers
on the increase in supply and the
pharmacies but kind of following up on
what um
kelly been asking too do we should we
look for the president to maybe move up
that july
fourth circle date that he had said
about americans being able to gather
uh in small groups can that also move up
now given that the eligibility is moving
up by two weeks
and the pace of vaccinations is
increasing
well we're certainly encouraged by the
fact that we are um
vaccinating our team as vaccinating our
experts across the country i should say
are vaccinating
an average about 3 million people a day
which is far
larger than any other country in the
world but we know
that it's not just about having a supply
or eligibility
it's also about people in the country
eligible adult americans
going to their community health center
going to a mass vaccination site going
to a pharmacy
to get vaccinated and get that shot in
their arms so
uh any changes we would make in advising
the public we would certainly do
in close coordination with the advice of
the cdc and our health and medical team
i don't have any expectation of that at
this point but we're always looking at
how we can provide clarity to the public
said that you know the lines might start
getting longer so seniors should start
getting
their shots now just to make sure
they're not doing it when it gets
clogged up
are you concerned that because the
eligibility has expanded
that the supply can match that and you
can still be on pace
to vaccinate all american adults who
want it by the end of the night
we will have enough supply by the end of
may um and we certainly
remain confident that we will continue
to be able to
provide the supply that states need to
vaccinate
people in their states and will continue
to
provide supply also independently to the
pharmacies which is a place a program
that has
started out as a pilot and has been
incredibly successful so
we are confident in what the path looks
like ahead but
we also uh constantly contingency plan
we know things happen
as trucks break down there are issues in
manufacturing sites as we saw
just last week and we are constantly
contingency planning about steps we need
to take to ensure we have adequate
supply out through all of our programs
the president continues to urge
americans to be vigilant we expect he'll
do that today in his remarks but over
the weekend we saw americans traveling
for the holiday weekend
we saw a totally packed baseball stadium
in texas yesterday
basically there are americans across the
country who are doing exactly what the
president is telling them not to do
is the message are americans not hearing
this or are they hearing it
and ignoring it you know i think the
president
recognizes that this has been a long and
difficult journey
for the american public uh we've been uh
the country has been shut down
in one form or another for more than a
year now and people have missed
birthday parties weddings baseball games
going out to restaurants it is difficult
it is hard
and what he's asking people to do is to
sacrifice a little bit longer
and he will continue to make that case
and make that argument
now while we saw uh the the baseball
game as you as you noted and
other events over the weekend and we
certainly anticipate as if the weather
gets warmer
there will be a temptation we've also
seen communities where
local mayors businesses have conveyed to
their uh
communities that we need to hang
together we need to remain vigilant we
need to wear masks
uh and we we will get through this
together so we are hopeful that
uh that that's exactly what the majority
of communities in this country will do
go ahead thank you um a couple of
clarifying questions on the
vaccine stuff one does this change the
date at all by which
there is an expectation everybody is
vaccinated
i mean this does that move up is there a
sense of having everybody to be
vaccinated well
getting to a point where the majority of
the american public is vaccinated is
about more than supply
so what this announcement is conveying
is uh we are at a point
with the supply we have available the
number of vaccinations
vaccines vaccination sites vaccinators
where we believe everybody in the
country should be eligible can get in
line by april 19th
many people will have been in line or
will even be vaccinated as we've seen by
the numbers before then
but it is going to take the american
people going
uh masking up socially distancing and
going and getting vaccinated we're gonna
make that as easy as possible but
there are roles that we can play and
then there are rules that the public
have to play
once they get in line on the 19th 19th
how long that line
ultimately may be there's not a new
update on that
i don't have a new update on that i
think it's just important for clarity
purposes to convey
it doesn't mean everybody will be uh
vaccinated by april 19 which is i know
why you're asking the question
it means that everybody will be eligible
to uh
go to their local pharmacy go to their
community health center
mobile vaccination site mass vaccination
site on that date and moving forward
one more unrelated to the vaccine over
the weekend there was reporting that
guantanamo a facility
was closed and some detainees were
consolidated
is that of the pentagon's
review of closing bitmo the president's
plan and in a timeline to potentially
make that proposal to close get more
uh the president remains committed uh
that is his desire and the outcome he
would like to see obviously that process
would be overseen
by the department of defense so i would
refer you to them for more specifics
about
those moves in that announcement go
ahead um
so another foreign policy question
president zielinski of ukraine
uh he has said publicly that um that
country needs to join nato
to avoid a war in the dongbas region
with russia we know that he brought that
up on his call
with the canadian prime minister did he
bring that up with president biden
on their recent call and
i guess more importantly what is the
president's view on that
issue well um
one uh that has long been the um
aspiration
of ukraine uh and one that has been
raised in a range of conversations
with u.s officials over the course of
several years
i would defer to them we would of course
defer to the ukrainian government on
reading out
uh what they raised um on the call uh
with the president uh but
you know in addition to uh we're all in
addition to our reassurances
that are consistently made uh to
ukrainian officials of our
support for them and support for their
sovereignty we're also discussing our
concerns about the increase in tensions
in the ceasefire violations
regional tensions with nato allies uh
and certainly what
uh would would uh be here to hear from
them as we have for years about their
aspirations and the process they need to
go through
an official white house position on
whether they should be able to
join nato soon is their position
again it's been an aspiration of
ukraine's for some time we've
long been discussing that aspiration
with ukraine we are
uh strong supporters of them we are
engaged with them uh and
working to push back on the
destabilizing actions uh but
uh that's a decision for nato to make
and we'll continue to be uh
you know uh recipients of their
interests okay you said a minute ago
that uh
the georgia voting rights law was based
on a lie
we had a poll yesterday that showed that
more than half
republicans believe that the election
was stolen
from donald trump and that
the capital riot was led by left-wing
agitators
um is there a public policy response to
this information
well first to disinformation in general
uh look i i think that um the prevalence
of disinformation is something that is
of concern to the president
uh he believes there is a range of
um reasons for it some relate to the
platforms uh some relate to the
individual actors who are promoting and
provoking uh
destabilizing activities and actions
through their rhetoric
he's spoken to that in the past um you
know this is certainly uh
an issue that the president is focused
on and he will
uh work with his team on under wrestling
through policy uh measures but i don't
have anything to preview for you
okay just one more quick thing on the
american jobs plan um
there's a moody's estimate that you have
cited
um basically their estimate is that 2.7
million jobs will be
created over 10 years to see if that
plan is passed
as it's been proposed um i think that
works out to something like 850
000 dollars per job given that
are you open to ideas uh about
a more targeted way a cheaper way of
achieving the same
goal in terms of number of jobs created
well
we're always open to hearing from
members of congress and on their ideas
and what they think should be
a part of the package at the end of the
day
the president's red line is inaction
he won't tolerate inaction on rebuilding
our nation's infrastructure something
that has
long been outdated he believes that we
need to
invest in that so we can improve the
lives of ordinary americans and make it
easier to do business
he also believes that investor
investment and long-term economic growth
will create
good paying jobs there was another study
that showed that about 75 percent
of these jobs the georgetown study i
should say uh would go
to workers who did not have college
degrees and that is certainly
a population in this country that needs
extra assistance and
it would be highly targeted in helping
give a leg up
to people who need that help he also
believes that we need to invest in order
to
help us out compete china and invest in
our own emerging economies to do that
and that we need to invest in the
american people that the american people
are the backbone of our
nations of our country and that is part
of our uh proposal in this package
go ahead go ahead thank you just two
questions
um one on vaccine again is any thought
being given to
a federally organized vaccine passport
of some kind
does the presidency that maybe is some
kind of tool that could be used or would
you lean more on the side of people who
raise objections over privacy
and so on well let me be very clear on
this i know there's been lots of
questions
uh the government is not now nor will we
be supporting a system that requires
americans to carry a credential
there will be no federal vaccinations
database and no federal mandate
requiring everyone to obtain
a single vaccination credential as these
tools are being considered by the
private and non-profit sectors our
interest is very simple from the federal
government
which is americans privacy and rights
should be protected
and so the so that these systems are not
used against people
unfairly there is a movement as you know
in the private sector
to identify ways that they can return to
uh events where there are large swaths
of people safely in
soccer stadiums or theaters um and
that's something that
uh that's where the idea originated and
we expect that's where it will be
concluded we will be
providing um some guidance which will
look like an faq
a frequently asked question i hate
acronyms but
that provides important answers to
questions that americans have in
particular around concerns about privacy
security or discrimination uh soon i
don't have an exact date for that yet
okay and if i might another question uh
on iran uh it's pretty clear what the
carrot is for iran that's obvious
but given that the previous
administration you know just after them
with pretty much everything you had
apart from
war um what's left in terms of the stick
when you're in entering these
negotiations what
what you know what what what is left
actually apart from war
what would iran want out of it
you know bring you back in and so on you
dismantle all this stuff and you know
we'll
eventually give you sanctions relief
that's pretty clear but
they withstood the sanctions under the
trump administration
and you know they they in fact only
increase their activity in the nuclear
well
if you go back if you go back
historically just a few years before the
trump administration to the obama biden
administration
sanctions were put in place which
incentivized in many ways getting them
to the table to have the discussion
about the joint
plan of action so look i would say at
this point
today is the first day of discussions as
you know these discussions are happening
in geneva and they are happening through
our european
counterparts and partners we expect them
to have
difficult portions we expect this to be
a long
process uh and we uh you know continue
to believe that a diplomatic path is the
right path forward
and there are benefits to all sides when
the trump administration
pulled out of the joint plan of action
what they left us with is a
far decreased visibility of iran's
nuclear capability
of what of uh inspections at their sites
uh of an understanding of how close they
were to acquiring a nuclear weapon
that's not in anyone's interest
certainly not the american people
go ahead jen um senator schumer's office
said last night that the
senate parliamentarian had ruled in
favor of additional
reconciliation bills i wondered if the
administration had
any view on that ruling and in light of
this ruling is this the likely path
that the president will take with the
senate in terms of getting this
infrastructure bill across the finish
line well the president
continues to believe uh less than a week
after he announced the plan i'll say
that there's a bipartisan path forward
and we are encouraged
uh not just by 80 percent of the public
that believes that we
it is long overdue to invest in
infrastructure that
not just roads rails and bridges but
there is a way we should
uh the federal role the federal
government can play in rebuilding the
infrastructure of our economy and
helping support american workers for the
21st century
uh this is a mechanism as you know
reconciliation
is a mechanism for passing uh budgetary
uh bills in congress we will leave the
mechanisms and the determination of the
mechanisms to
leaders in congress but right now less
than a week
after he announced the american jobs
plan our focus is on engaging
with democrats and republicans with
staff with committee staff
inviting members to the white house next
week and we are encouraged
uh by some of the statements that have
been made
about components of the package where we
could find agreement
on infrastructure some republicans have
quibbled with
the way infrastructure should be defined
in the bill does the person feel he has
to convince
republicans of what should
be used in an infrastructure bill before
he
can actually persuade them to vote for
it
well i'll give you a little bit of a
homework excitement um
there are some republicans who have
previously called for
investment in workforce development as
part of comprehensive infrastructure
investment
some have called for that uh some have
previously called for
investing in broadband and the expansion
of broadband as a means of expanding
infrastructure some even have a
reference to replacing pipes
as a means of infrastructure so i would
suggest that
many of their constituents would be
surprised to hear that those are not
infrastructure projects
and i'm sure with a little googling you
can all figure out who those all are
um at this press conference the
president said our children and
grandchildren will be writing
doctoral theses about uh whether
democracy or
autocracy succeeded what was his own
measure for success there is it american
gdp versus chinese gdp ultimately or was
it
the sphere of influence of both
countries around the world
it's a big broad question a good one um
look i think the president is uh when he
talks about that he's not just talking
about economic growth and development
that certainly is part of it
he's also talking about our values and
what message we send uh
to the world and to our children and so
it has quite a broad meeting and that's
i think reflective and
reflected i should say and how he has
approached
his presidency and identified the crises
we're facing
you know i think he wants he has
grandchildren now so maybe he wants the
rest of us to be able to tell
our grandchildren what role did we play
in addressing racial injustice
what role did we play in addressing the
climate crisis what world did we play
in helping rebuild the workforce of the
future and what role did we play in
standing up for our values around the
world
so has quite a broad meaning um but
you know i think that's a reflection of
his approach to his presidency
is he using the competition with china
point
uh as a key selling point with
republicans on on infrastructure and and
perhaps in a way that
an appeal in other areas is not going to
work the idea that there's a danger
falling behind china
does he hope pragmatically that will
strike a chord
well there is agreement across democrats
republicans frankly the american people
that we need to do more
to invest here at home in order to
compete with china
and uh he has conveyed too that his and
i have i guess as well
that our approach to our relationship
with china is to come
to that relationship from a position of
strength and that includes
investing at home ensuring that our
workforce our infrastructure
our broadband access is at a rate where
it would uh
come it would it would strengthen our
own infrastructure and workforce here so
that we can
compete globally uh there's also been uh
proposed legislation i'm not sure if
it's been formally dropped yet but to
um by senator schumer and others that is
focused on
how we can better invest in our
workforce to compete with china we
anticipate there's an opportunity for
that to be bipartisan because
investing in workforce in our workforce
here is something that democrats and
republicans can agree on
is the president disappointed by the
pace of vaccine distribution
in the districts of colombia and does it
potentially strengthen the argument for
statehood
well he's spoken about stated in the
past but i would say that
uh you know we track every community we
track every state
and locality and how distribution is
going and
how to improve it and make it more
effective and we work very closely
with leaders one size doesn't fit all
and some
in some cases that means we increase
distribution to pharmacies we increase
distribution to
mobile vaccine sites and so that's
certainly something that's ongoing with
leaders around the country including
of course with leaders in the district
of columbia
go ahead in the back
i want to follow up on the vienna talks
um so is the white house satisfied or
content
by this first round of talks between
what they call the p4
plus one and iran well we're only on the
first day
so i will i will allow the team that is
negotiating on the ground to give more
of an assessment of how they feel the
talks have gone
explain if these talks are indirect
between the europeans the russians and
the chinese and iran
why do you have a high ranking u.s
official in vienna
since you don't want to talk directly
with the iranians well
i think it's important to convey to the
our partners our p5 plus one partners
too that we
believe diplomacy is the best step
forward is the most appropriate step
forward and
rob malley who is somebody who's
experienced who's been a part of
negotiations in the past is
certainly an appropriate level
individual from the government to be
there so is the white house position
tell now that no lifting of any
sanctions
until iran comply well i think we expect
that as i conveyed yesterday that a big
part of the conversation will be
uh how iran can come back into
compliance and what would be required of
the united states but uh we've been
clear
uh that we are um not taking not
anticipating any
uh steps at this moment will allow the
negotiations to to continue
and allow me on iraq tomorrow uh you can
avoid the strategic dialogue between the
united states and iraq
um as you know the president has been
talking about reviewing trump's numbers
all over the world including iran is
this a topic that obviously
behind center on these talks what do you
expect from these talks how are they
different from the previous one
under the previous administration well
one uh
these meetings will further clarify that
coalition forces are in iraq
to at the invitation of the iraqi
government and solely for the purpose of
training and advising
iraqi forces to ensure that isis cannot
reconstitute and i
think that's a difference from how it
was described previously
this will also be an important
opportunity to discuss our mutual
interests across a range
of fields from security to culture to
trade and climate
and obviously these are proceedings soon
and i'm certain we'll have a
readout once they once the discussions
conclude
thank you go ahead thanks jen um
bloomberg reported earlier today that
president putin plans to take part in
the virtual
climate summit later this month is the
kremlin reached out to confirm his
attendance
i'm sorry say the last part one more
time has the kremlin reached out to
confirm his attendance
uh we've invited about 40 heads of state
to attend the climate summit and i
expect as we get closer we'll have
confirmation about
who will be participating in the summit
okay and one more
senator mcconnell's comments yesterday
to encourage republican men to get to go
get a vaccine
was the white house in touch with
senator mcconnell uh
in as part of the effort to address
vaccine hesitancy or was the president
in touch with him before he made those
comments i don't have any private
conversations to
pre or to communicate about but
certainly we see it
as a positive for any member of congress
uh democrat or republican to be out
there advocating for their
supporters uh people who follow them who
listen to them about the safety and the
efficacy of the vaccine
uh go ahead thank you um following up on
some of what ken was asking about
reconciliation
um for there to be a sort of second
fight of the reconciliation apple so
this week
it would have to be by the end of the
school year um and concerning what you
just said about
from the fight the only red line is in
action does present vitamin c there'd be
a deadline for congress to move
on the job plan would you like to see it
by the end of the fiscal year or by the
end of the calendar year
you'd like to see progress by may and
certainly a package
through by the summer and then
um on uh afghanistan
um we're getting very very close to the
may 1st deadline
uh to pull out the remaining 3500 troops
it doesn't frankly look like the white
house is going for the administration's
going to meet that deadline
um why at this point should
the american people have confidence in
your ability to finally end this war if
you're not going to meet sort of this
initial death
well first it wasn't a deadline we said
um
but the president this president uh has
conveyed that it would be difficult
operationally
to meet the timeline of getting all
troops out by may 1st
he has also consistently over the course
of the last decade
spoken out about his concerns about the
war
and that has consistently been his view
even back when he was vice president and
it wasn't aligned with everybody else in
the administration
so that should hopefully give people
confidence about
his commitments but it's also an
important decision
one he needs to make in close
consultation with our allies and also
with our
national security team here in this
administration and we want to give him
the time to do that
good afternoon what does the president
who we know is catholic
say to catholic doctors catholic
institutions
who are fearful that if the equality act
passes
it has potential to trample on their
conscience rights what does the
president say to those
people he has a difference of opinion
and he respects their difference of
opinion but uh he has been a supporter
of the equality act
uh and he also is a practicing catholic
and attends church
uh nearly every week oh good
yeah a separate question here um
chicago saw 131 homicides through march
of this year last year this time
98. the white house's reaction to that
number
and then is there anything the federal
government is planning or
willing to do to step into the city of
chicago and tamp down the deadly
violence just recently a 13 year old boy
was shot and killed there
well i appreciate you raising the fact
that there's a prevalence of violence
sometimes at the hands of guns uh
something the president has
uh fought for throughout his career
which is
ensuring that we put it in place more
gun safety measures we work with
communities
to invest in community violence
prevention he's actually proposed
funding to do
exactly that something that many groups
support
because they believe in order to reduce
violence in order to address
the prevalence of violence in
communities like some in chicago
uh that we need to spend the money from
the federal government to do exactly
that
put any resources right now immediately
rather than waiting for laws
waiting for you know community events or
what have you to take place
people are dying on the streets by the
day again i
appreciate you raising it because some
one thing we don't talk about enough
is the fact that beyond mass shootings
there are additional people who die
in cities sometimes young kids nearly
every single day as a result of violence
he has proposed funding uh we would
support acting on that and that's we'll
continue to advocate i think we've got
to move on go ahead kelly
is the administration looking at how
you're going to talk about the number of
jobs
created from the infrastructure package
because citing the movies numbers
uh from a secretary buddha judge and
brian he's talking about 19 million
when that was really talking about a
much longer time frame
so since you aren't giving us
administration centered numbers how
can you add some clarity to where the
numbers uh for
jobs should be if uh the secretary and
mr beast
overshot in their comments well i think
as the secretary said
in an interview yesterday it is
important to be clear and to be
specific about jobs numbers to provide
clarity to the american
people and it will be hard to have state
by state we'll have state by state fact
sheets out soon i think
but it'll heart be hard to have state by
state job creation numbers because we
won't know the specifics because of all
the
bidding processes that will take place
as it relates to infrastructure
but moody's ran an analysis that showed
that the economy
would create 19 million jobs over the
next decade
if congress passes the american jobs
plan almost 3 million more
than if it doesn't so that is the that
is what the impact would be of the
american jobs plan 2.7 million to be
totally clear um these are millions of
jobs that won't be creative congress
doesn't act
to pass this plan we see that as a
positive
but we also uh will be very clear in our
articulate exactly what numbers of jobs
it will create
thank you everyone